les policiers sont invités par leur
syndicat se rassembler devant les
commissariats ou à ne plus traiter que
les urgences façon pour eux de
manifester leur ras-le-bol après la
tentative de meurtre de viry châtillon
ils ont été confrontés une bande de
sauvageons qui ont agi avec lâcheté un
sauvageon ces gentilles et là ce sont
des hommes qui ont voulu tuer le point
ministre a raison de dire qu'il ne faut
pas qu'il y ait de zones de non droit
mais il ya mais à mon avis il y en a
beaucoup à reconquérir la délinquance
d'aujourd'hui et ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui qui est une américanisation
de la violence moi d'abord je pense à sa
politique entre la vie et la mort mais
je vous réponds renseignements moi je
réponds pas aux questions j'ai bien vous
répondre en question où elle va bien
répondre aux questions en chine à la
preuve
quelques secondes plus tard lorsqu
audrey crespo-mara la lance sur eric
zemmour le pauvre je le plains je plains
pas mais surtout sa famille ses enfants
mais je le plains mais voilà c'est tout
moi j'en fais pas une obsession il a
fait une obsession mais moi je trouve
que vous la vie tu y es et savoir vous
rentrez de moscou alexandre orlov est ce
que vladimir poutine veut toujours lui
venir à paris deux heures plus tard
vladimir poutine a annulé ce matin sa
visite prévue à paris le 19 octobre
françois hollande hésiter sérieusement à
le recevoir à cause du profond désaccord
sur la syrie le dialogue est nécessaire
avec la turquie mais ea avec la fesci
mais il doit être ferme et front sinon
il n'a pas sa place le porte-parole de
la présidence russe a fait savoir
vladimir poutine reste disposée à
visiter paris lorsque le président
hollande se sentira à l'aise pour le
voir je suis donc prêt à tout moment a
rencontré le président poutine
mais si nous avons la possibilité de
faire avancer la cause de la paix
l'annulation de la visite est une très
mauvaise chose
cette stratégie qui consiste à faire la
guerre froide avec la russie est une
erreur
c'est invraisemblable président de la
république qui soit encore une fois qui
est versé dans cette diplomatie
d'opérette ce qui nous a
particulièrement intéressé yann lors de
cette petite visite sur le port c'est le
déjeuner d'alain juppé avait cassé la
croûte
il a cassé la croûte avec le sénateur
jean jacques panunzi actuellement
poursuivi pour favoritisme détournement
de fonds publics et recours au travail
dissimulé
je me suis exprimée et je crois que les
français ont compris et qui montre
légitimé à plusieurs reprises je
voudrais ajouter une seule chose je
réponds pas beaucoup de l'état de droit
tous ces personnages que vous citez m'en
que l'état de droit la bouche qu'est ce
que c'est que l'état de droit c'est la
non réactive rétroactivité de la loi
pénale
il y avait le maire d'ajaccio laurent
marc angeli qui a déjà connu une
élection invalidée pour manoeuvres
frauduleuses
alors c'est sûr que pour s'afficher
devant les journalistes il ya mieux
comme table vous savez en matière
judiciaire vaut mieux avoir un passé
comme avenir
qu'est ce que vous avez pu composer une
table plus irréprochable ce n'est pas
moi qui fut brisée à l'idée de toute
façon moi je respecte la présomption
d'innocence alors si vous faites la
chasse transformez-vous en juge